das ist mein auto und mit ein bisschen
ausstattung können wir daraus
tatsächlich ziemlich einfach in den
camper machen und wie zur hölle dass in
diesem doch relativ kleinen auto
funktionieren soll und ob es tatsächlich
praktikabel ist finden wir heute heraus
viel spaß mit ich habe meinen tesla zu
einem campingmobil umgebaut vorweg ich
liebe mein auto voll elektrisch über 500
kilometer reale reichweite alles wird
übers handy gesteuerte innenraum ist
clean ist fakt und man hat vorne wie
hinten eine menge platz aber das letzte
was man vermuten würde ist dass man in
diesem auto kämpfen kann natürlich
funktioniert das auch nicht direkt von
haus aus sondern wir brauchen etwas aus
statt bevor ich euch aber die
ausstattung und alle features zeigen
mussten uns erst mal auf die reise
machen denn für dieses video brauchen
einen gebürtigen ort an dem es sich auch
lohnt zu kämpfen also ab richtung
schweiz
nach 8 stunden fahrt tatsächlich
angekommen und der größte vorteil daran
wahrscheinlich in dem campingmobil
unterwegs zu sein ist kein festes ziel
haben zu müssen wir hatten eigentlich
ein festes ziel haben sie jetzt aber
kurzfristig doch dafür entschieden nach
nur samen zu fahren weil hier sieht so
aus
[Musik]
okay es ist wunderschön aber wie sollen
wir das jetzt anstellen zu zweit in
diesem motto drei zu schlafen denn ich
bin nicht alleine sondern ich habe kater
leo dabei hat und wir werden gemeinsam
im modul drei schlaufen wie machen wir
das ganze
hat eine durchgängige fläche vom
kofferraum bis ganz nach vorne wenn wir
die sitzung klappen schauen wir mal
ihren freien sehen wir
wenn wir ohne sitzbank hinten die
eine komplett gerade fläche die genau
zwei meter lang sein sollte und wir
haben ein meter platz außerdem gibt es
eine luftmatratze die genau in zwei drei
rein passt denn wir sind nicht die
ersten die auf die idee kommen im model
3 zu kämpfen darum kümmern wir uns als
erstes dann gilt es essen zu machen denn
dafür haben uns auch überlegt dann heißt
es schlafen und das ganze austesten wir
haben zwar überall wo es bcm model 3 wir
haben aber trotzdem einen altmodischen
ganz normalen 12 volt anschluss mit
bitte luftmatratze auf blasen können
werden
[Musik]
das ist unser bett
zu krass und es sieht viel besser aus
als ich gedacht hatte und fühlt sich
viel besser an als gedacht hätte ein
absoluter traum
das bett steht und wir werden jetzt
gemeinsam mal testen wie gemütlich das
ist und ob man wirklich zu zweit genug
platz darin hat ich bin ziemlich groß
bin fast 190 alter ist so geil ja
da ist er weg was ich kann auch weil ich
brauche einen kranken mann kann sich
wirklich perfekt hinlegen es ist
wirklich gerade so naja aber an und für
sich ist das wenn man morgens aufwacht
und auf dem rücken liegt da hat man
wirklich den himmel direkt über sich man
kann direkt sich die morgensonne an oder
haben sich derartig stern wir haben
definitiv genug platz und die sitze sind
noch längst nicht auf ihrer vordersten
positionen die sitze können wir nutzen
um unser gepäck da liegen zu haben
unsere klamotten und vielleicht auch das
essen das wir gleich noch zubereiten
werden
dadurch dass wir kein getriebe kein
aufruf keine sachen haben die von vorne
bis hinten durchlaufen haben wir noch
eine menge stauraum trotz der
luftmatratze und zwar direkt hier
drunter wo sich unsere koch sachen
befinden aber dass nicht der einzige den
wir noch komplett nutzen können sondern
und den kombinationen aus diesen beiden
sachen ergibt ein vollwertiges kochfeld
ich habe immer einen tisch dabei der
perfekt auf den fahrersitz passt so dass
ich während ich im laden bin arbeiten
und hessen kann dieser tisch passt aber
auch genau in empfang um daraus eine
arbeitsfläche zu machen und hier
unser meisterwerk von nudeln mit pesto
es fehlt das geld wieder abzuschütteln
und dann aber noch ein platz zu finden
wo wir die vernünftig essen können aber
ich habe das schon so eine idee
es ist angerichtet
ich hab sofort draußen ist mega im
winter es tatsächlich und entspannter
als es aussieht aber ich habe meinen
tisch ausgebreitet hier nicht arbeiten
heute abend werde ich den tisch aber
nutzen um hier vernünftig zuerst gut
und was hat das ding wir sitzen jetzt
hier haben beiden sitzplatz und hinter
uns aber jetzt das bett folge legt mit
unseren sachen die finden aber wenn wir
im bett sind platz auf unseren sitzen
also wir haben sitzmöglichkeiten im
tesla eine schlafmöglichkeit eine
möglichkeit zu kochen so lange es nicht
regnet und wenn es regnet muss man es
halt mit regenjacke machen aber auch
leno ist das ein absoluter traum das
einzige ding was wir nicht an unsere
rechnung miteinbezogen haben ist es am
berg schräg ist deswegen werden wir uns
einen anderen platz als diesen zum
schlafen suchen kann dahin und dann
zeigen wir euch noch was man so
entertainmentwise für möglichkeiten im
tesla hat was der camping modus alles
kann und das fazit wie die nacht so
wirklich gerne da oben geblieben ist
wichtig dass hier ihr können und nicht
am hang stehen das gut ist ja überall
hinstellen genau wir können uns überall
weil wir haben wir an tester mit
matratze das genau hallo jungs was geht
ja mit solchen lage kommt also die
kamera gesehen
sind gerade extra noch ein stückchen
weiter gefahren wir stehen gerade und
können hier jetzt vernünftig schlafen
und ich kann euch alle funktionen zeigen
alle funktionen ja denn das 0 3 ist
nicht einfach nur ein auto mit einer
matratze hinten drin sondern es hat
camping funktionen funktionen die extra
fürs campen sind nicht welche die man
fürs campen nutzen kann sondern extra
camping funktionen was das model 3 aber
natürlich nicht hat ist ein bad in dem
man duschen kann oder fließend wasser
hat wie macht man das also
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber du bist keine den schönen der aktie
nehmen ist schön fähigkeit
24 stunden
job ich danke camping macht erfinderisch
und das nicht nur bei uns oder was meine
sondern anscheinend auch bei den
entwicklern von tesla alle die von euch
schon im auto geschlafen haben wissen
dass es eine sache gibt die absolut
gratis und zwar kondenswasser man muss
quasi wenn man nachts irgendwo im auto
schläft die fenster und spalte oder
sogar nen ordentlichen spalt offen
lassen weil der körper eben einfach
arbeitet es kommt zur feuchtigkeit die
sammelt sich im auto und dann wird es um
entspannt und um dem entgegenzuwirken
hat tesla einen extra camping modus
entwickelt beginn noch diese kleine
lüftungs rädchen und oben rechts in der
ecke sehen wir verschiedene optionen aus
an und und eben auch camp
in diesem modus tauscht das auto die
luft hier drin die ganze zeit das
bedeutet wir haben frische luft keine
contents und von uns gewünschte
eingestellte temperatur man könnte jetzt
meinen dass es eigentlich gar nicht so
ein gast feature ist aber wer schon mal
konsens beim campen im auto erlebt hat
weiß dass es unheimlich nervt und so
eine funktion in dem auto zu haben
ändert alles zumindest im camping sinne
aber was kann das auto eigentlich noch
so
neben kleinen spielereien die ich
wirklich camping feeling aufkommen
lassen können wie diesem hier
die sitzheizung der dann aus den
lüftungen kommen warme luft dieses video
läuft und der passende sound wird dazu
abgespielt gibt es auch noch eine menge
möglichkeiten auf der unterhaltungs
seite wir haben durchgehend lte ich
glaube sogar weltweit und wir können
hier unten auf unterhaltung zwischen
netflix youtube tritsch und tesla
tutorials auswählen dazu gibt es
natürlich noch eine menge spiele und das
läuft tatsächlich wirklich gut wenn ich
jetzt hier also schlafen gehen kann ich
ganz entspannt wie zu hause auch zum
einschlafen noch ein paar youtube videos
gucken und so sieht das dann aus nur
dass ich nicht meine eigenen videos zum
einschlafen leo telefoniert übrigens
draußen mit seiner freundin wenn ihr
mich fragt wurde ist
[Musik]
ja die nase ist vorbei wir haben zehn
prozent akku verloren es ist überall
glas und ab 7 uhr 30 wurde so fucking
hält in alter ich musste mich die ganze
zeit unter der decke kostet und das ist
mein fazit
die nacht im test lama gut aber war sie
so gut dass ich wieder machen würde
grundsätzlich ja nicht begeistern die
features mich begeistert dass es möglich
ist eine matratze so vernünftig hätten
reinzulegen das camping modus gibt dass
man diese ganzen entertainment
möglichkeiten einen campingurlaub würde
ich aber probieren zu vermeiden das ist
einfach dann doch ein bisschen wenig
platz und klar ist funktioniert alles
das entertainment ist super aber eine
woche da drin jetzt mit zwei leuten dann
auch noch zu schlafen kann ich mir
weniger vorstellen ich denke jetzt dass
viel mehr dafür gemacht einfach eine
nacht oder dritten mal schnell eine
lacht bei einem kumpel auf einer party
kennen weil kein platz mehr im haus ist
irgendwie eine nacht irgendwo auf der
autobahn überbrücken weil man die
strecke nicht mehr in einem durch
schafft campen gehen würde ich damit
tatsächlich nicht in mode oder molé kann
das schon wieder ganz anders aussehen
model 3 ist aber so eine art kopie der
ist einfach wenig platz es hat trotzdem
eine menge laune gemacht cool zu sehen
dass in irgendeiner weise funktioniert
wenn es euch auch spaß gemacht hat was
der modernen ikt da vergesse ich hier
kanals abonnieren und dann sehen wir uns
am sonntag
[Musik]